everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in the
final round around 13 of the 2016 tata
steel tournament Magnus Carlsen has been
leading this tournament from at the
beginning so I thought what better way
then to end it with Magnus Carlsen but
we have a pretty interesting story on
our hands Magnus Carlsen is up of points
on his opponent today playing the black
pieces is ding lien from China he's a
point behind Magnus Carlsen what this
means is even though he's in third place
if he were to win this he would be tied
with Magnus Carlsen now Fabiano is in a
second place half a point behind Magnus
Carlsen so if he were to win Magnus
Carlsen loses Fabiana is the champion if
Magnus Carlsen losses in Fabiano it's
highs we have a three-way tie so a lot
riding on this match now Magnus Carlsen
does just need a tie here to claim the
victory but he likes to play for the win
in anything he's playing so definitely
gonna be a pretty exciting match today
if you're not too familiar with his
opponent England from China
he's 23 years old he got second in this
tournament last year only a half a point
behind Magnus Carlsen so extremely
talented player this 23 year old has the
highest rating highest rank ever for a
Chinese player in the world he's
currently ranked 12th in the world but
all in all a fantastic fantastic Chinese
Grandmaster so we'll go ahead and get
into it pretty epic match today Magnus
Carlsen starting out with Pondy form
gala
Magnus Carlsen playing the aggressive
openings so many times pond e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop here to b5 getting into
the riot Lopez we do see the morphe
defense pawn to a6 we've have seen that
Birdland offense for a while but more if
you defense has kind of been the way
that blacks defended it this and this
tournament Bishop back here to a4 and
then 9th f6 castle on the Kings side so
kind of going more for that open line
where we see the knight come down here
capture on a 4 and then pawn here to d4
then pond b5 and then Bishop back here
to b3 the main line continues with black
pawn to d5 pawn takes here on e5 Bishop
to e6
to solidifying this pawn here on a d5
and then Knight to d2 and White has a
few options here usually kind of the
classical lines would be pawn here to c3
or even Bishop here to e3 just develop
moves both of those are fine
Karpov used to play this night here to
d2 back in the 78th World Championships
played it's a great success from here
you know exactly what madness Crossland
played we c9 here to c5 upon here to c3
and in those seventy championships
kind of the the popular move was pawn
here to d4 probably not as strong as
what Dean played which was Bishop here
to e7 this is kind of the the more
popular move nowadays so this is the
line that they took in the game now the
bishop comes back here to see - and then
pawn to d4 so we see black putting a lot
of pressure starting to push forward in
the center of the board now Knight here
to b3 and magnus carlsen has a few
options if he wanted to he could take
here pawn takes here on d4 the knight
could take knight recaptures Queen takes
Knight to f3 we could see an exchange
with the Queen's on board but the Queen
could continue to be aggressive if you
wanted to Queen here to b4 pawn a3 Queen
here to c4
this is going to be completely fine
Magnus Carlsen decides to go and play
Knight here to b3 and then we see
continued push forward with pawn here to
d3 and could also take if you wanted to
take here on c3 could take we could see
the knight captured Bishop capture the
pawn take this is going to be fine as
well so so many variations they could go
down but both of these players not
spending too much time really feels like
they've prepared for this and so they
like these variations that they're going
down so after pawn here to d3 we do see
the knight capture here on c5 and then
the pawn take so black has a double
bishop pair but not for too long the
Knights gonna come here to e6 I'll
gobble that up and then we see Bishop
here to e3 so White has completed his
development he's got all his pieces
involved into the game connected his
rooks and then all kind of black has to
do is castle on the King said if he
wants to doesn't have to he could just
continue to develop his King into the
game once the Queen's come off the board
you really just kind of want your King
to get involved into the center of the
board
really a powerful piece so we may not
even see that castle on the kingside
first we do see rook here to d5
attacking this pawn so both sides have
seven ponds on the board so it just kind
of depends on what madness Carlson wants
to we could try to hold on to this pawn
if he want to or he could just attack
this pawn right here he decides to go
and attack the pawn so rook here to see
one now the Knights gonna take Knight
recaptures here on e5 rook to e5 Bishop
here to e5 forcing the rook to move also
attacking the pawn here on g7 Dean kind
of has two options he could try to hold
on to this pawn it's gonna be futile
though that there's no way for him to
really hold on to it rook here to e2
King here to F one I'll send a rook here
to d1 Bishop here to e3 there's kind of
stopping this pawn is going to follow
the rooks are just going to come back
here so we count looks at the sides okay
you know that's not going to do too much
so I'm gonna just swing my rook over
here to g5 protecting this pawn I know
I'm gonna give up this pawn here on c2 I
don't want to give up any more material
so Magnus Carlsen now decides to go and
take rook here on a c2 and then King to
f7 so even compared to that early a
variation where Magnus Carlsen started
to have a little bit more tempo getting
his King involved with King here to f1
this saves black just even that one
little move which is always nice his
King is more involved in the game at the
Magnus cross him with this game here on
g1
Magnus responds with Bishop e2 e3 just
attacking the rook rook swings here to
e5 pawn to c4 trying to break up the
Queen side pawn b4 now we're over here
to d1 controlling this long a center
file we do see an exchange on board and
now King over here to f1 getting it
involved into the game and if you can't
look at it it's gonna be tough for any
side to really have a strong endgame
right here they both have equal amount
of material so the game is definitely
equal on board it's gonna be someone's
gonna have to make a mistake for this
game to end in a win which bodes well
for Magnus Carlsen but Bishop down here
to to g5 what's really nice about Magnus
Carlsen is he could just easily take
right here it's you know he could take
her on g5 just continue to force down
the material to
just the Kings on board he could get it
easy drawl take home the victory money
with the trophy all in all it be great
tournament for him but he decides hey
this is the last round
you know a lot of people come to these
tournaments to see the world champion
and you know he wants to win every match
even if he's kind of already got it in
the back so he doesn't take right away I
decided to go and play Bishop here to
deep D for continue to attack his
opponent rook over here to a5 paneer to
b3 kind of really the only way to stop
this attack on a to solidifies his pawn
chain and then opens up for his rook
here on c2 to stop that attack a bishop
here to f6 Bishop down here to e3 still
does not want to give up that bishop but
you're you to g5 now pawn up here to f4
says okay let's start to just push
forward see if we can get some attack
see if we can put black in a tough
position here and so Bishop back here to
e7 pawn push forward here G force at
Magnus Carlsen is on the attack on the
kingside paneer to h5 pawn h3 and then
pawn g6 then we see the King get more
involved King here to e2 we do see
exchange on the board upon here to e5
just trying to break up the center of
the board King here to f3 pawn takes
Bishop takes now Bishop here to d6 now
we see the pawn come up here to c5 you
know kind of interesting the bishop
could take here if you wanted to this
just putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent decides now to go ahead and
take now this Bishop is going to take
here on at c7 attacking the rook and out
rook here to a b5 King here to e4 King
here to e6 so both sides do a good job
of getting their Kings involved into the
action Bishop over here to f4 rook here
to a5 and then a bishop here to d2
Bishop over here to e7
we're compared to c6 it's a king the
King and then the brooks wings over here
to g6 so Magnus Carlsen has a passed
pawn on the board but as you can see he
did have his rook here on c2 that was
kind of the last line of defense for
this pawn on a 2 so he decided I'm gonna
go ahead and give up that pawn here on
a2 because I want to have a pass
pawn here on the G file and start to put
pressure on my opponent also keep in
mind that if you are going to push your
pawn to the eighth-ranked you always
want to look to see if your opponent has
a bishop and see what color that's on so
magnus carlsen he can push up here to
the eighth-ranked his opponent has a
dark square bishop it's not gonna be
able to defend this square right here so
it kind of puts black in a tough spot
where he knows that Magnus Carlsen can
just kind of push up the board really
defend this pawn and eventually get a
promotion here with this passed pawn so
he's definitely gonna be in a lot of
trouble right now he needs to go and get
that material back so rook down here to
a to capture that material bishop here
to f4 since his bishop was being
attacked and then we're here to a3
attacking this pawn here on a b3 we see
magnus carlsen push forward with g5 says
i'm gonna give up that pawn I'm gonna
allow you have to passed pawns over here
because my past pawn is a little further
up the board so after here we see the
rook take now the rooks gonna swing over
here a to b6 and this is basically
saying okay I'm not gonna allow you to
do anything too crazy you can't get your
rib too involved I'm just gonna take
this pawn so it kind of keeps this rook
at bay here it also attacks this pawn
here on a 6 or anything crazy and black
has a tough decision to make as well he
could play pawn here to a5 maybe starts
to push forward he could just completely
give up this pawn so he's up upon the
material right now and say okay this
pawn up here is too dangerous I'm gonna
get my rook involved into the game but
as soon as I move my rook I'm gonna lose
this pawn but that could be completely
fine or the other option which exactly
what he decided to do is I'm gonna give
up my bishop because this pawn is so
powerful he's so besides okay I'm gonna
go ahead and give up my bishop and then
start to push forward with my pawns now
he knows that magnus carlsen can no
longer promote to a queen so this is the
max that magnus carlsen is gonna be
fighting with the whole game it's still
gonna be difficult for magnus carlsen to
get a win with this material he's gonna
have to you know chip away take these
pawns eventually still make this rook
disappear because it's you can't
actually checkmate your opponent lest
they make a mistake with just a king and
rook first a king rook and a bishop
but first we're gonna play rook over
here to a6 pawn here it's a four so
black decides okay I'm gonna give up one
of my pawns right here my past pawn is
valuable to me and so I'm gonna go ahead
and start to push forward with that
we're here to a three in madness Crossin
this is another one of those times where
he could have just decided that he could
take here after the pawn takes Bishop
here to e3 even if we see you know the
pawn push forward this is another one of
those cases where we have a dark square
Bishop the pawns gonna promote to a dark
square Magnus Carlsen can hold on to the
square and it's going to be a drawing
game Magnus Carlsen can't win with just
a bishop but he looks at this and said
you know what this is a you're offering
me a draw incensed by playing this I
didn't come here to get a draw I came
here to put pressure on my opponent
continue to push forward to the end of
the game so he plays rook here to f5 now
pawn to b3 so hey box says okay if
you're gonna do that I'm just gonna push
my pawn as much as possible and now he's
pushing towards a white square right
here which the dark square bishop is not
going to be able to protect so Magnus
Carlsen needs to kind of protect the
next-best square which is the square
here on b2 now black plays rook here to
a2 just allowing himself some protection
if you were to play pawn here to b2 and
then a bishop here to d4 pawn here to B
2 and then that we're going to swing
over here to c5 King here to a b6 and we
see a discovered attack it didn't really
matter where the King moves if we were
to move here - you know rook to d6 all
of a sudden rook to b5 two attackers
defending the square here on b1 also
just putting two attackers on the square
here on a b2 as well so and you know we
see this King come here - to b6
discovered attack rook here to c3
forcing the King to move now the works
wings over here to b3 check now the King
comes here to see for broke up here to
b8 so still protecting this pot this
pawn pushing forward here to b1 the rook
can't really move because then the
bishop is gonna swing down here and just
take the pawn and this King can't really
move anywhere he has this entire kind of
blocked off right here has no
moves no legal moves from this position
right here so he's kind of stuck right
now oh you'd really need is just a night
right here to be really nice to go ahead
and check
checkmate really weird checkmate but
can't move his King right here so
instead decides okay I have nothing else
going for me I can't really move my pawn
I can't move my rook because then the
pawn leaves so who decides okay I'm just
going to give up this pawn right here
and then it's just defense mode for kind
of a long time we are in move 58 right
now it's just kind of a he knows that he
can't win the game
he knows madness grausens only one that
can essentially win the game so his goal
right now is just to tie the game and
this really comes down to Magnus Carlsen
really likes to grind down his opponents
he's the best in gameplay in the world
he probably has the best endurance
probably one of the more athletic
players out there and so he he's fine
playing hour-long matches and grinding
them down so this is I feel like Magnus
Carlsen thrives on this type of
environment we see busy period III rook
here to see to now the work swings up
and you see kind of just lots of
movement
what black wants to make sure he does is
he doesn't have any crazy thing where
his King gets too far away from his rook
so you know there's some Czech and then
his King has to move and his rook falls
he doesn't want to doing that wants to
make sure that he keeps not both his
King and his rook on dark squares
because dark square bishop you could all
this all of a sudden get some sort of
fork or some sort of pin down pinning
the King down to the rook capturing the
rook all Magnus Carson really needs is
this rook here of his own so if he can
exchange off his bishop or the rook
that's going to be fine so you know
black doesn't have to worry about too
much in the game but those are some of
the high-level things that he's gonna be
thinking about for the rest of the game
so King here to d5 King b3 work over
here to h7 and then both sides just kind
of moving around you can see black
hanging out on these light squares which
is always nice so he kind of moves just
protecting his King all over so many
different moves we're already on move 74
magnus carlsen it what's crazy is though
any mistake that
why it makes in this game just results
in him losing he has to be so precise in
all of his moves that it's it's just
crazies we kind of move over here you
know we can all of a sudden see you know
King here to g4 Bishop down here to F to
King here to h3 even if we look at this
position right here we did see you know
ding he plays after a bishop to f2 King
here to h3 but he could easily make a
mistake here after a bishop here to f2
we could see rook here to h2 maybe wants
to start to try to get creative get
aggressive but then all of a sudden rook
here to g8 forcing the King to move the
King can't come to any of these squares
because the King can't stay on the G
file can't come here to h4 you know
that's gonna be bad so let's say he
comes here to h5 if it comes here to h3
this is also going to be bad you can
just get the King more involved into the
game you could say you know King here to
f4 then the rooks gonna move and then
work here to h8 that's gonna be
checkmate that's gonna be extremely bad
but you know King here to h5 and all of
a sudden of rook here to h8 the rooks
going to fall after the King moves let's
say King here to g6 this is going to be
a good game for Magnus Carlsen so as you
can see that kind of any of these moves
that we look at it there's just any sort
of mistake from black side Magnus
Carlsen is going to win the game but
King here to h3 King f3 rook here to g3
King f4 rook g4 King f5 rook g7 Bishop
here to d4 centralizing attacking the
rook rook comes back here continue to
keep those pieces on the light squares
is black doing a really good job of that
we're here to e2 and you can see Magnus
Carlsen is trying everything in his
power to find some sort of mistake you
know but but things just not having it
very skilled player this is kind of one
of those in games where early on you
just kind of learn this and you you know
what to expect and you try not to make a
mistake
especially at this high level you just
don't see too many so King here to f3
rook here to f2 and this is sort of a
nice fitting into the tournaments Bishop
takes here on f2 and this is a stalemate
so the king can't move but because he's
not in check this is actually a drawn
game and this was the 99th move in the
tournament one of the longest tournament
matches that we've seen in a long time
but Magnus Carlsen with the draw ends up
winning the tournament
Fabiana Caruana actually lost his match
he was going all out trying to get the
win and ended up losing so we have you
know being actually from from China
getting tied for second with Fabiana
Caruana so second year in a row he gets
second place only 23 years old I expect
great things from him in the future he
played a really solid game against
Magnus Carlsen but what can you say
Magnus Carlsen he's the world champion
he does what he does he comes to
tournaments he crushes I really like the
fact that even in the last round his
opponent essentially offered him draw
after draw Manas Carlson says no way
we're playing till the very end
99 moves you really can't ask for more
from a world champion it was pretty
interesting
they were asking some of the competitors
they were playing in the candidates
tournament and in March kind of the the
big tournament to decide who's gonna
play Magnus Carlsen later in the year
for the World Championship gonna be the
biggest tournament we're gonna cover
that as well but they're asking a nice
giri they're like who's gonna win the
candidates tournament and he said no one
knows you should find a tournament that
Magnus Carlsen is actually gonna be
playing on and just bet on Magnus
Carlsen because he's the best in the
world and he really is he holds you know
all the blitz in the rapid chess
tournament championships right now he's
the world champion and just normal play
I don't see anyone right now stopping
him I do hope that some of these these
younger players as they're getting
stronger that they eventually can
challenge him buff right now the world
is mad as hell since he's too strong any
wins the second year in a row the Tata
Steel tournament so can
gratulations to magnus carlsen yet again
at the champion hopefully you guys
enjoyed this tournament had a lot of
really fun games that we've covered so
be looking out for the candice
tournament that's going to be the next
tournament that we are going to cover
that's in early March and that's going
to be a big one six to the top players
in the world that they've kind of been
qualifying for the past two years so
make sure you mark your calendars for
that one and I'll see you guys then
thanks for watching